it's difficult to think of an anime and
manga property more suited to join Omega
forces warriors metaseries than berserk
franchise protagonists guts lives and
breathes hack and flashing although he
at first glance can be mistaken for a
one-dimensional mercenary obsessed with
killing unfortunately berserk and the
band of the hawk simplistic gameplay
does little to demystify the shallow
perception
it's an inadequate introduction to the
Warriors games although the abundance of
anime and CG cinematics makes it a
fitting gateway to the berserk series
even if it doesn't do its main character
any favors for a manga series that has
lasted over 27 years spanning myriad
story arcs it was wise of a mega force
to focus on preserves most well-known
events namely the narratives that have
been adapted into various anime
productions the result is a
comprehensive story mode that chronicles
guts his evolution from raging teenage
mercenary with no life goals
to a homicidal adult seeking retribution
wizard is representative of warriors
games that their most simple and
straightforward which when compared to
their recent achievements with Hyrule
warriors and Dragon Quest heroes is all
the more disappointing assignments are
limited to three types Destroy rescue
and kill the game of region dominance a
hallmark of dynasty Warriors campaigns
is barely utilized and would have added
depth to desserts 46 story chapters at
its best moments amassing a body count
of over a thousand while completing
goals in a single mission feels
cathartic but there's never the
compulsion to wipe an entire map clean
of enemies to do so would add monotony
to an already tedious campaign when the
drive to pick off objectives and reach
the next cutscene becomes more appealing
than staying on the battlefield despite
the multiple objectives the occasional
mid-mission plot twists and all the
running around the majority of chapters
can take less than 10 minutes to
complete what results are missions that
are shorter than the cinematics that
frame each chapter
you're intermissions in the first third
of the story mode reprises scenes from
berserk Golden Age film trilogy while
players are spared from footage of the
device of new TV show in favor of new CG
scenes its plot heavy by warrior
standards but works in the context of
guts as epic road to revenge guts is
brutal and offensive minded repertoire
is expressed through the simple combos
that make up much of his moveset it all
comes down to how many quick and strong
attacks you string together after every
hundred or so killed guts can unleash a
finishing move that wipes out every
nearby foe
such carnage is fitting for him though
it's easy to see how such a sense of
routine can set in quickly and often
without a greater variety of objectives
a mega Forces brand of unrefined hacking
slashing becomes all the more magnified
as you labor through the lengthy
campaign free mode a staple of the
Menace series serves as an outlet to try
out berserk supporting cast they all
control with the same quick attack
strong attack simplicity of guts each
with their own brutal flourishes where
two dozen troops can be vanquished with
a single sword stroke the androgynous
Griffon kills with the lethal grace of a
fencer while the skilled catskil moves
with the agility of a ninja
the novel appeal of playing someone
other than guns loses its allure quickly
since free mode only features previously
beaten story missions berserks
repetitiveness is all the more
pronounced in endless eclipses the
game's endurance mode
despite its seemingly intimidating
100-round design this mode lacks
character as it's neither tower dungeon
nor is it a hectic wave based survival
mode it mimics the story modes
prioritization on completing objectives
with no penalty for running past the
lesser enemies in each round it
underscores berserks lack of replay
incentives
despite the character building rewards
it bestows when completing missions in
endless Eclipse boredom is as much of an
obstacle as anything that's most throws
at you given how well guts as bloodlust
and battle experience are well-suited to
the crowd fighting and mass slaughter
Warriors games it's disappointing that
this tie-in lacks the engagement and
nuance of omega forces more imaginative
efforts with other franchises it's
saving feature is the expansiveness of
the campaign narrative which serves as a
hearty sampling of the berserk
franchises multiple story arc if not for
these insightful cutscenes the
developers penchant for adequate but
unengaging hack and slash combat would
perpetuate the image of guts as a
one-note protagonist and even if you're
a Warriors fan who knows not to expect a
Dark Souls level of gratifying melee
combat fan of the Hawks still deprives
you of the juicy sights and sounds that
one associates would gut to savagery